Listen to a cancer webinar last night advocated hydrogen water. Do you have opinions of hydrogen water better to drink or breathe hydrogen air?
So yeah, there are some there's some data out there about hydrogen water and cancer
Hydrogen water and just general health. That is very intriguing. So I
Think that I don't see anything wrong with using hydrogen water
You know, we did those about seven or eight years ago. We cut it in a deep dive on that first came out and
The only thing I had against it is that you know with our patients
We haven't been doing a lot of things already and one of our philosophical things is
Trying not to make the have the person spending their whole day on different therapies. I don't if you have a hydrogen water machine
I think that's a great thing to use
Echo water. Yeah, echo water was actually a machine that
That we research. I think it's a good good tool